Narrator: These are the Sharks.
They have achieved incredible
success as entrepreneurs
and investors
in multiple sectors.
They all came
from humble beginnings
and are all self‐made.
The Sharks know what it takes
to build business empires
from nothing into billions.
Now they are investing
in entrepreneurs' dreams.
Sharks, this sucks.
Ew!
You've created
an armpit diaper.
If you boil it down.
Wait for it.
Both: Boom!
They went to Harvard
Business School?
Narrator: This is the art
of doing business.
And your sales are...?
I have sold 200.
Oh.
Narrator:
This is "Shark Tank."
We want to have
a positive impact
on the people
of Afghanistan.
You're not
in Afghanistan.
You're in
the Shark Tank now.
You have to know
your numbers.
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a solution
to an embarrassing problem.
Our first victims.
[ Chuckles ]
Hello, Sharks.
My name's Billy Thompson.
Hi. I'm Randy Choi.
We're from Orange County,
California,
and our company
is the Thompson Tee.
We're seeking $700,000 in
exchange for 7% of our business.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, God!
Sharks,
this sucks.
Ew!
This doesn't suck.
[ Chuckles ]
Even one of you Sharks
have experienced
this sucky situation.
[ Laughter ]
Aah!
John: Oh, that is nasty.
No, take it down!
Take it down!
Robert,
give these guys 700 grand.
[ Laughter ]
Thompson: Sharks, that's why
we invented a solution
to this embarrassing,
age‐old problem ‐‐
an undershirt that completely
blocks underarm sweat.
Choi: It's called
the Thompson Tee,
with Hydro‐Shield
sweatproof technology.
All of our
"raise your hand,
don't let them
see you sweat" shirts
come with an unconditional,
30‐day, sweatproof guarantee.
Wear it,
wash it, dry it.
Sweat‐free in more ways
than one.
Proudly, our shirts were
handcrafted here in the U. S. A.
So, which one of you Sharks
want to help us
get rid of this sucky situation
once and for all?
We brought a Thompson Tee
for each one of you.
Cool.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Greiner: Thank you.
John: Thank you.
Cuban: Thank you, sir.
Yeah.
Cute.
So, Randy,
wear an undershirt
underneath a great shirt
like this,
it will stop you
from sweating,
and it'll protect
the outer garment.
Correct.
What's the difference
between the one
I'm wearing right now
and yours?
Well,
look in the armpit.
Yeah,
look at the armpit.
This is,
like, triple‐layered.
No.
No, no, no.
They have a Kotex
underneath the armpit.
[ Laughter ]
That's the difference.
But you're just
a basic undershirt
with padding.
Correct.
It fees like,
in the entire underarm,
you've reinforced...
It feels like a...
...and put, like,
three layers of fabric.
What you had to do is,
you can't just slap
a waterproof material
against your skin.
It'll actually
exacerbate the problem.
So we had to come out
with a way to mitigate
that thermal heat
transfer.
But it's just three layers
of cotton, right?
No, that's incorrect.
Inside, the inner layer
is an ultra‐thin,
four‐way stretch,
compound polymer,
medical‐grade film
that allows
vapor to pass through...
Oh, really?
...but will block moisture.
So there is something
proprietary in this?
Absolutely. We do have
a patent on the product.
So, you've created
an armpit diaper
for people that really sweat
profusely.
Basically.
Pretty much, yeah.
If you boil it down,
correct.
So, Billy,
it's three layers ‐‐
Now ‐‐ Now,
before you tell us
the sales, because...
Yes.
...a really crazy number here,
but, you know,
I like to get, like ‐‐
You know, I'm romantic.
Don't go into
valuation yet.
Like, you got
to hear the story.
I want to hear the story.
Randy, tell us the story.
Now tell us the story.
Yeah.
Well, I mean,
it goes way back.
I mean, I was in 7th grade,
and I pitted out.
That's way back, man.
Yeah.
I'd prefer you started
in grade 1.
[ Laughter ]
Well...
7th grade mattered,
because that's when...
Maybe in the womb.
Puberty ‐‐
That's when it happens.
So, I reached out
to Randy.
Randy and I
were kind of mutual friends.
I knew he was in
the apparel business.
I grew up
in the apparel industry.
And it turned out
that he actually had
a form of hyperhidrosis,
which, by the way,
is the clinical term
for excessive sweat.
He knew exactly
what I was doing,
and he became passionate
about it,
'cause he understood,
and he partnered with me.
What percentage of people
have that problem?
1.5% have this problem,
and then another 35% deal with
it on a situational basis.
Randy,
agree with me on this.
Yes.
99% of the guys,
if they simply wore
an undershirt,
it would get rid of
some of the sweat.
It will definitely get rid
of some of the sweat.
Some. Some.
Correct.
Well,
here's a good example ‐‐
you,
in that picture.
You say
you always wear one.
But I was doing
incredible exercise.
[ Laughter ]
Or is this for people
with a serious sweat problem?
It's for the 35%
of the population
that's buying clinical‐strength
antiperspirant
for those situational meetings,
weddings,
first dates, job interviews,
and this stuff
is not working
for them.
How much does it cost?
It comes in two different ‐‐
two different lines.
We have the original fit,
which fits
like a traditional undershirt,
and then we have the slim fit,
which fits more
to the contours of the body.
Right. How much?
Original fit is $24.99.
The bamboo line
is $29.99.
What's your cost
to make them?
We average about $8.50.
Herjavec:
How do you sell them?
We sell everything
direct to consumer,
online, at our website
and then also on Amazon.
And your sales are...?
On year 1,
we did $90,000.
Year 2, we did
half a million dollars.
Year 3,
we did $1 million.
And year 4,
we did $2 million.
Wow.
Year‐to‐date,
we are at $2.6 million,
on pace
to do $4 million.
What are you making
on the $2.6 million?
25%.
I'm surprised.
You're not crazy, then.
Whoa. Wait a second.
Thompson: Thank you.
Thank you.
You want a $10 million
valuation.
Who's paying more
than 10 times for T‐shirts?
Good question.
Patented T‐shirts.
Yes.
But, guys, the technology ‐‐
"technology" ‐‐
is fine, right?
It serves the purpose.
But you're really
a marketing company.
Yeah.
That's what you are,
right?
Because you found a niche,
however big it is,
and you figured out
how to digitally market,
retain your margin,
and you continue
to grow your
customer base.
And you're killing it.
So, the main question becomes ‐‐
you're making money,
you got expertise in
manufacturing and in sales ‐‐
what are you here for?
Well, we'd like
the capital to bring
our production
in‐house.
How much would you lower your
cost if you brought it in‐house?
We estimate about
$2 to $2.50.
Why do you want to take
that time
to then take on
the manufacturing?
Because then you're
gonna lose time
doing what you're doing best ‐‐
getting out to the customer.
Cuban: 'Cause then you're gonna
go through the ‐‐
you're gonna go through
that learning curve,
and just managing
all those people
and dealing with those hassles
that come with it.
Yeah.
Herjavec: Randy,
I don't have a problem
with you wanting
to bring it in.
I get it. $2 on an $8 item ‐‐
that's a huge margin.
Right.
Here's my only disconnect.
Not to be a Kevin,
but you're asking
for 2 1/2 times your revenue
as a valuation.
How do you get to
a $10 million value today?
Because of the ‐‐
the size of the market,
the historical growth,
the lack of alternatives.
But the truth is,
you can spin the story
any way you want,
but in the end, it's a T‐shirt.
I'm out.
I normally would say that you're
crazy about the valuation here,
but I'm not mad at you
for asking for that amount.
But my biggest challenge...
is inventory.
Taking on
that whole process
of warehousing
and buying machines...
I really don't want
to be in that space.
I don't want to go down
that path with you, so I'm out.
Gotcha.
Okay.
Under‐‐ Understood.
Guys, one of the challenges
sometimes for entrepreneurs
is knowing what business
they're truly in.
The reality is
you're a marketing company.
If you would've come here
and said, "$700K,
we're getting 2x
on every dollar we spend,
and so we think, with $700K,
we can increase that
and go to the next level and get
3x on every dollar we spend,"
that would've
been different.
That would've been
an acknowledgement ‐‐
"Yeah, we truly are
a great marketing company."
And this is what scares me
about you guys.
I'm out.
Understood.
Okay.
Billy, I like it.
I like it. I mean...
Here we go.
...I'm the only guy up here,
you know...
Who doesn't sweat? Yeah.
... wearing an undershirt.
I always wear an undershirt.
I actually think
it's a wider market.
It amazes me that,
looking even up here,
that most guys don't know,
not only for the sweat,
but it makes the outer garment
look better, cleaner.
Some of us are just cooler than
the other side of the pillow.
[ Chuckles ]
But there's risk,
obviously.
Here's what I feel
comfortable with.
Here's the offer
that's not
gonna make me sweat
and stay up at night.
[ Laughs ]
I'll give you the $700,000
for 25%.
Ouch.
Right in the middle
of the range.
Am I wrong, Kevin?
Nope.
That's a reasonable offer,
and you will never
get a better one
than that.
Greiner: Okay. You're obviously
doing a great business,
and it's working.
The interesting thing to me,
being in the TV industry
for so long,
when you put on certain fabrics,
like silk or satin,
they don't breathe,
and it's a nightmare.
Right.
And so I can relate
to what it is.
I love it, but can I get
really excited about it?
This is a tough one,
guys.
You came in asking
for a lot.
You'd be shocked.
You'd be shocked
with these testimonials
that come in every day.
Being in the apparel industry
for as long as I have,
it's the first time I actually
worked with a brand and product
that's actually
helping people.
It's a pretty, uh...
I love you guys,
I like the product,
but I'm out.
Bam! [ Laughs ]
Whoa.
Wow.
But all is not lost.
1 Shark, 2 Shark, 3 Shark,
4 Shark out.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Narrator:
Four Sharks are out.
Billy and Randy
only have one offer
on the table from Robert
for their sweat‐repelling
shirt company, Thompson Tee.
$700,000, 25%.
Gosh, my offer looks
so much better now.
$700,000 for 25% of the company
puts us at $2.8 million.
Robert, where do you see
the growth in this company?
In what direction would you
advise us to take it?
You know,
my investment is in you guys.
Yeah, it's a T‐shirt,
but you guys
are the fabric
of the company.
I'm making
my investment in you.
I'm not gonna tell you
what to do,
but I am gonna give you
some direction.
It's up to you to do
what you want with it.
Continue to do
what you're doing ‐‐
Okay, listen.
I'm getting frustrated
listening to this,
so I'm gonna
put another offer in
just so you have
an alternative.
[ Laughter ]
You're boring me
to death.
I'll give you the $700K
as a loan.
I'll take
the 7% equity now.
I'm gonna charge 18%, which is
what your industry gets paid.
Oh, Lord.
There's an option.
You have no delusion.
Basically, you pay me 7%,
I give you $700,000 loan,
36 months at 18%,
1.5% a month.
I'll do it right now.
I'll give you
Louis' number.
You can just go
down the street.
18% interest?
Absolutely.
I'll do it right now.
Herjavec:
I have no interest in debt.
The way I've made money up here
is by investing
in entrepreneurs,
doing the operations,
and growing the business.
My offer is $700,000,
25%.
I just want to do
the equity.
You guys...
You guys have to make
a decision,
or I'm gonna invoice you
18% for my time.
[ Laughter ]
You got a deal.
All right.
[ Applause ]
Dang.
Congrats, Robert.
Robert.
Congrats, guys.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Guys, congrats.
Thank you.
Appreciate that.
He would've taken 20%.
[ Laughter ]
Can always counter.
All right.
Should've countered.
All right, guys.
Okay, I'll do it at 17%.
[ Laughter ]
Congrats, guys.
Good luck.
Thompson: I just can't believe
we got a deal.
'Cause my dad had passed
unexpectedly on Sunday morning,
so I know he'd
be proud right now.
[ Voice breaking ]
And I just, you know...
I wish he could've
physically been here to ‐‐
to see this,
but I know
he's here in spirit,
without a doubt.
Narrator: In season 7,
Wombi Rose and John Wise
made a deal with Kevin O'Leary
for their pop‐up
greeting‐card company
lovepop.
Spectacular. And I have so many
customers that would buy this.
Let's see
what's happening now.
Rose: Business has been popping
since "Shark Tank."
We just sold our
millionth lovepop card.
Wise: Prior to "Shark Tank,"
we had done
$300,000 in a year
and a half.
It's now been a year,
and we've done
$8.7 million in sales.
The growth
has been incredible.
We now have 200 people
working at lovepop.
Hey, guys, how are you?
I'm in Boston today,
so I came over to see
the lovepop guys.
They want to show me
something brand‐new.
Wow.
These look very different
than anything else
you guys have done.
In every award show,
there's always
that magic moment ‐‐
"The envelope, please."
And I thought to myself,
"Why isn't that a lovepop card?"
I know the people that produce
the Billboard Music Awards.
I put them together,
and magic.
Oh, wow.
The Billboard Music Awards
are gonna be
on ABC on May 21st,
so this is
a fantastic opportunity
to get lovepop
out there.
When the winner's
announced,
not only will the audience
hear who has won,
they'll see who's won
in a lovepop.
This could be very good
for the brand.
I invested in lovepop
for two reasons.
Number one, they took something
old and made it new again,
but the team,
Wombi and John,
are really delivering
for investors.
$8.7 million in sales ‐‐
That's huge.
I will see you soon.
And you know where?
Billboard Music Awards.
Wise: Starting lovepop
has been
the most rewarding
experience of our lives.
We've learned, we've grown,
and we're continuing to do more.
We had such an amazing
opportunity to build
this company and to have
this experience
that we never
would've imagined.
Who's the Top Artist?
Mr. Wonderful.
Yeah, baby.
[ Laughing ]
Get it.
Guys to the front.
Girls and guy
in the back.
Whoo!
Man:
We are 20 seconds away.
Cuban: Kabam.
Narrator: Next up is what
the entrepreneurs believe
is the most convenient way
to carry your essentials.
[ Laughing ]
[ Chuckles ]
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Trevor Johnston.
And I'm Justin Johnston.
We're brothers and best friends
from Northern California.
And we're the creators
of the Wallet Buckle.
We're seeking $500,000
for a 10% equity in our company.
[ Chuckling ]
Wow.
Trevor:
Yeah, I know, I know.
Oh, wow.
You guys are thinking,
"These guys are crazy
if they think they're gonna
get that valuation
over a belt buckle."
Yes.
But trust us, Sharks.
The belt buckle ‐‐
the Wallet Buckle
should be approached
as a brand‐new
fashion accessory,
never before seen,
and we're taking
the nation by storm.
[ Chuckling ]
Imagine this.
Go out to your
favorite music festival
or at your favorite
sporting event...
Cuban.
...pop in line,
grab some food and a drink,
and the terror
sets in.
"Where's my credit card?
How am I
gonna pay for this?"
Don't be that guy ‐‐
that guy holding up the line,
that guy everyone is cursing
under their breaths.
Both: Well, not anymore!
With the Wallet Buckle,
you are now able to access
your cards and I. D. quicker
than any other form of payment.
Wait for it.
Both: Boom!
Boom.
Still not convinced?
Fine.
What if your girlfriend's
literally attached at your hip?
[ Laughs ]
I don't even need to put
my girlfriend down
to buy her next drink.
I just whip
my card out.
[ Laughter ]
And the love
never stops.
Kevin.
The Wallet Buckle
will allow you to carry
up to five cards safely
and securely
right inside
your belt buckle.
But even if you have one card,
they are all tension‐held,
so they're
not gonna fall out.
So even if you have one card,
just slides right in...
and doesn't fall out.
Once you wear a Wallet Buckle,
you'll wonder why
you've never worn
a Wallet Buckle before,
which is why we've brought
you all your very own,
as my assistant,
Sexy Sam,
will bring your
very own Wallet Buckle.
I need that rhinestone
one on you.
John: You know,
I've never seen...
Thank you, Sexy Sam.
...anybody laugh
at their own pitch so much.
All right, which one's
the rhinestone?
[ Laughing ]
We like to have fun.
Thank you.
So, these buckles,
as you'll see,
they are ‐‐ They'll go on
any snap‐on belt,
so most ‐‐
most stores that actually
already sell belt straps
love this idea
just because they're
already selling belt straps,
so you can actually mix
and match your belt straps.
Herjavec: So, I ‐‐ I ‐‐
Great presentation.
Great schtick.
It's actually
a really good product.
It's one of those
that makes me say,
"Why hasn't anybody
thought of this?"
But there's a big elephant
in the room.
$500,000 for 10%.
Well, when I said we're taking
the nation by storm, I meant it.
I meant it.
So, we just started selling ‐‐
The very first event
was at Stagecoach,
which is a big country‐music
festival right out here
in Southern California,
last year.
So it's been
about 18 months, so ‐‐
and we've sold upwards of
about 15,000 units.
Trevor, can you ‐‐
And how much are you selling
them for at ‐‐ at ‐‐
Between $40 and $95.
15,000 units last year.
What are the total sales?
No, not last year.
Last year,
we did only $250,000 in sales.
This year, to date,
we're already over $500,000
and projecting close to $800,000
by the end of the year.
It sounds good.
So let's go through one.
What's the average cost
of a buckle?
What does it cost you to make,
and what do you sell them for?
So, any of just the colored ones
right here are $49.95.
All right, so let's take
one of those, $49.
What does it
cost you to make?
Currently, about $7
but it can be as low as $5.
What's the breakdown
of sales?
Where have you
been selling them?
About 80% of the sales
are done in live events,
and when I say "live events,"
it's festivals,
it's concerts,
rodeos.
So, Justin,
can we go through next year's
optimistic sales scenario?
Tell me,
as good as it can get,
what revenues are gonna be
if everything works out.
Absolutely.
So, we just got picked up
by one of the largest denim
retailers in the country ‐‐
Well, just give me a number.
I don't need the adjectives.
I think we're gonna
be $2.5 million, $3 million.
Let's make it $3 million.
Yeah, what would
your margin be on that?
I want to hear
about that retailer.
Who was it?
Buckle.
I've never heard
of Buckle.
So what kind of store is this,
and what do they sell?
They sell, I believe,
two out of every three pair
of denim in the country.
O'Leary: You got $3 million
in sales.
What are we making, pre‐tax,
on this business?
$450,000?
Yeah, $450,000.
Why the lederhosen?
[ Chuckles ]
I mean, you can't not
have fun in this, right?
Is that the buckle
you wear all the time?
Yeah, I had this belt custom
made, actually...
'Cause it attracts a lot of
attention and questions?
as well, to match, so...
Looks good, right?
Yeah, I like it.
[ Laughter ]
I missed that.
Would you do that again?
[ Laughter ]
O'Leary: When you display
the buckle in Buckles,
how does anybody know
that it stores credit cards?
So, we opened our first kiosk
in the mall
to get Buckle's
attention.
So, I moved out to Nashville
three months ago,
and I told the mall in there ‐‐
I did, really. There it is.
And so I literally moved out
to Nashville,
and I told the mall,
"I want my kiosk
to be right
in front of Buckle.
Do you have to pay
to put that kiosk in?
$67 a day.
So you have
this in malls.
That's the first location.
The second location
opens up in two weeks.
We want to have
at least 40 by June.
O'Leary: Just humor me.
Yeah.
Great year's $3 million
in sales.
You're gonna make $450,000
pre‐tax, $300,000 after tax.
You're telling me
this business is worth
$5 million
or about 16 times
what you're gonna make
in a good year.
You think that's a little
aggressive for a belt buckle?
You'd think so.
We have about $1 million
of inventory already.
Why do you have $1 million
of inventory?
We'll blow through that.
We're ready to go.
We've done events where we'll do
30 Gs in three days.
Yeah, but between those days,
you have to travel,
you have to set up,
there's a cost.
So that's $200,000,
at cost.
We bought a tour bus.
You bought a tour bus.
A tour bus?
Trevor:
I've been literally touring
the entire country.
Every single weekend,
it's been a major
country‐music festival
the last four months.
You know, when you guys
came in here,
I was skeptical
about the valuation.
[ Laughs ]
Given what you've said...
They've done themselves
a cruel disservice.
...and based on all
of the attributes...
You're thinking $10 million,
aren't you, Kevin?
I'm thinking $15 million.
I don't want to take
advantage of you
and get a whopping 10%
for $500K.
It's just so unfair.
I'm out.
[ Laughs ]
Herjavec: You guys
are killing it.
I see you guys
at the Calgary Stampede
or any rodeo
or something like that.
You're gonna kill it.
But the credit card,
just the size of it,
for a belt buckle,
on a general suit,
is never gonna work.
I‐I think
this is pretty limited.
Not for me.
I'm out.
So, here's where I am, guys.
I like the product.
80% of your sales right now
are going through live events,
and that means that you guys
are the salespeople.
I mean,
the schtick is funny.
I'm ready to buy one now
just because
we fall in love with you.
But when you sell now
to kiosks, number one ‐‐
and those are your kiosks? ‐‐
all that inventory's yours.
It's always on the books.
It never comes off the books.
When you sell to retailers,
nobody can tell
what that buckle is.
And the reason I know this
is because I have a company
named Mission Belt,
and I also have a company,
Myself Belts, and unless
the salesperson is wearing it
and they're obsessed with it,
they don't sell.
And that's
the biggest challenge.
So you have a good business
for yourself.
$5 million valuation's
absolutely crazy.
I can't help you
with this.
I'm out.
Guys, look,
I live in Dallas, right?
And in Texas, big belt buckles
are not unusual.
It's not that
there's not a market.
It's just, I don't think
it's a big enough market for ‐‐
for what you're trying to do.
Designing belt buckles
to turn this
into a $50 million company ‐‐
That's gonna be hard.
I'm out.
And then
there was one.
Yeah.
So, my concern is
men wear belts a lot.
They wear pants a lot.
A lot of women are changing up
from dresses,
skirts, pants ‐‐
you know, everything ‐‐
and maybe don't wear belts
that often.
So, while you're doing
a great business,
but because I feel like
it's rather niche,
I'm out.
Hmm.
Thank you, guys.
Good luck, guys.
Congrats.
Justin: They missed out
on a huge opportunity
for a product that's
gonna go big and go viral.
And people are fanatical
about it.
Narrator: Next into the Tank
are veterans
hoping to help farmers
in a war‐torn country
by capitalizing
on a rare commodity.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
I'm Kim.
I'm Emily.
And I'm Keith.
We're from Chicago, Illinois,
and we are Rumi Spice.
Sharks, today,
we are seeking $250,000
in investment in exchange
for 5% of our company.
What do you think about when you
hear the word "Afghanistan"?
Perhaps war,
terrorism, opium.
Those are the reasons
we went to Afghanistan
as U. S. Army soldiers.
I supported Special Operations
on night raids.
I was a Route Clearance
platoon leader,
looking for roadside bombs.
And I was an Afghan
regional expert,
working
with tribal elders.
While we were deployed,
we saw a very different
Afghanistan.
Afghanistan is a land inhabited
by proud people
with a rich culture
and history ‐‐
and covered in fields
of violet‐colored flowers.
In these precious
purple flowers
lies the rarest
and most expensive
spice in the world ‐‐
saffron.
It's the queen of all spices
and worth its weight in gold.
In modern‐day cooking,
there is not risotto Milanese
or paella that is complete
without saffron.
Sharks,
after 30 years of war,
Afghanistan, once a progressive
and peaceful country,
has been cut off from
the international marketplace.
So, before returning home
from our deployment,
we wanted to figure out a way
to empower these Afghan farmers.
So we built a business,
working directly with them,
and we've now created a market
for premium Afghan saffron.
Now only one
question remains ‐‐
which one of you Sharks
will join our mission
to cultivate peace
and harvest profits
for yourselves and for
our farmers in Afghanistan?
Today, we have prepared
something very special
for you guys to try.
We want to show‐‐
We always love that.
[ Laughter ]
So, we wanted to showcase
the versatility of saffron,
because it's both in savory
and sweet applications.
Herjavec: Thank you.
Mm‐hmm.
So, our chef made
a saffron ghee,
like a saffron butter, drizzled
with lemon zest over yogurt.
And on the sweet side,
a saffron‐infused honey drop.
And you guys also have
the Rumi saffron gift.
There's 2 grams in there.
I know saffron
from paella.
Yep.
But this almost
smells like tobacco.
So, saffron you might've been
used to is saffron
that's maybe two,
three years old,
and it's lost that sweet smell
of the saffron
that comes fresh
from the harvest.
And where do I get
saffron today
if I don't get it
from Afghanistan?
You can get it from Spain,
although Spain exports a lot
more than it actually grows,
so 90% of the world's saffron
actually comes from Iran.
So when you're buying Spanish
saffron, more than likely,
you're buying
low‐quality saffron
that's changed
many hands.
And Afghanistan saffron,
for three years running,
has been named the best‐quality
saffron in the world.
How do you trade it?
What does it sell for per ‐‐
per what?
So, on retail,
we sell 1 gram for $18,
and then we also sell
in the restaurants,
so we have it
at $140 per ounce.
Okay. And why is it
so expensive?
It's so expensive because
there's no automation.
It all has to be
hand‐processed.
It's insanely
labor‐intensive.
It takes 150 hours
of labor
just to produce 1 gram
of saffron.
So, how much does
this bottle sell for, retail?
$35...
Man.
and it cost us $8.30
to make.
Well,
let me ask you something.
The pricing
that you have here,
whether it's the valuation
or whether it's the product,
is ‐‐ it's high,
and that means it's
gonna be a limited market,
and that means you may
or may not be able
to help the people
that you're trying to help.
We're absolutely
a luxury brand, right?
We are at the high end of the
market selling premium saffron.
But what we do
with the money that we make
is we reinvest
that profit
back into the infrastructure
in Afghanistan.
We are definitely in it
to make money.
We are a for‐profit company,
but we really believe
that making a difference
is also important
and that we want to
have a positive impact
on the people
of Afghanistan.
O'Leary:
What are your sales?
We've made $400,000
in sales so far.
We've projected $750,000
this year.
Wow.
So tell us about the sales
of saffron in the United States.
In the United States,
it's a little over
$60 million,
so it's not big.
Way bigger
than I thought.
Well, how do you compare it
to another spice?
The spice market is about,
I think,
over $10 billion,
so it's a very small part of it,
but it's
the highest‐grossing.
We're not really
in the spice industry here.
We're talking about building
a brand around saffron
and doing other
saffron‐related products.
So you want to turn
this into a brand.
Mm‐hmm.
Right.
One, how are you gonna
turn it into a brand,
and, two, who's your primary
customer going to be?
So, we want to reach
the end consumer,
so through our partners
like Blue Apron,
also through speciality
retailers ‐‐
Well, Blue Apron, you're kind
of hidden in there, right?
You're an OEM type ‐‐
No.
It's our story,
it's our packaging.
We're being featured
in their meals.
So, we do want to be
in retail ‐‐ specialty retail.
We have already worked
with Daniel Boulud,
Chef de Cuisine,
to do a Rumi saffron butter.
We have different spice blends
with saffron in them,
and we're looking at things
like saffron tea.
I mean, think about the size
of the tea market.
What do you see as your biggest
political risk?
I don't think there's
a political risk,
because we're operating
with the farmers,
we're giving them an incentive
to produce,
and we're giving them
an incentive
to protect
their investment.
Okay.
Kim, how did you guys meet?
How did you guys meet?
So, Kim and I met during
emergency operations
on Hurricane Sandy recovery
on Manhattan Island.
And the way we started
this business,
I was deployed
to Afghanistan
in one of the most
dangerous provinces.
And I met this farmer,
Haji Yosef,
who was selling
this incredible, vibrant
red spice
called saffron.
At the time, I didn't know
anything about saffron.
I did some research,
I found out Afghanistan
grows the best‐quality
saffron in the world.
So I thought,
"Who's better to call
to make this a business
than Kim and Emily?"
who were at
Harvard Business School.
Hang on a sec.
They went
to Harvard Business School?
That's correct.
We went to West Point
together, too.
Just small
accomplishments.
Here's what
I think about it.
First of all,
thank you for your service.
It's an honor.
I love what you're doing.
I really do.
As a PAGE ambassador
and all of us Sharks,
we believe in entrepreneurship
and helping people,
because if you're helping
all these people in Afghanistan,
they're able to feed
their families
with an honest day's living.
So I love that.
My biggest challenge is,
the product is just
too expensive
for the everyday person,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
Greiner:
So, I'm a huge foodie.
I go crazy for truffle ‐‐
truffle anything.
Miller: Yeah.
Truffle.
Truffle oil,
truffle fries.
Saffron, to me, feels like
the equivalent of a truffle...
Exactly.
Exactly it.
Greiner: ...in a spice.
It's expensive,
it's a premium,
and a luxury.
I love you.
I love what you're doing.
The statement's great.
The problem for me is,
I personally
don't like saffron,
so I'm out.
O'Leary: Can I just ask?
Your forecast for this year is
to break even on the $750,000?
Yes, break even.
But, actually, by next month,
we'll be profitable.
And next year, you said you're
going to make $1.5 million.
How much will you make
on that?
I mean, I would estimate
probably 5% net income.
5% pre‐tax?
Herjavec:
But, Kim, why?
Why is the margin so low
for such a high‐gross margin?
Why is the net margin
so low?
So, I just did
that from comps,
from what I read
from other food and beverage,
but this is, you know ‐‐
this is ‐‐
this is a guess.
I think we can actually
be a lot higher.
And with your help,
we can be.
I got to tell you, Kim,
for a couple of Harvard grads,
I'm a little surprised
you don't have your model
nailed down
a little more.
They do.
No, they don't.
Greiner: Well, Kim,
let me ask you this.
No, they don't.
Yes, we are Harvard grads,
but we're not perfect.
I mean, I was just a Harvard
grad last year, all right?
[ Laughs ]
Most of my education
has been what we've been doing
this last year.
You guys are the ones
who know the stuff.
This is why we're here.
We're bringing to the table
what we've done so far.
Listen, I think
what you've done is great,
and I also would say
that many of us
love to invest
in people that have served,
because the military provides
a certain discipline
that applies well
to business.
My problem with you
is I don't think
you're worth $5 million.
When I asked you how much money
you were gonna make
on the $750,000,
the answer was zero.
A multiple of zero
is still zero,
so I can't value it
that way.
So I have to ask myself,
"What have you built,
to date,
that's worth 5 million bucks?"
I don't see that.
A lot of what
we've built to date
has been in the infrastructure
in Afghanistan.
We're gonna hit profitability
in the next month,
and that's when you're gonna see
our margins grow.
We run a high‐margin business,
guys, and it's growing.
No,
you're not, apparently.
Yes, we are.
You said
you were gonna make 5%.
Well,
that was my guess, right?
Just because based
on other food and beverage ‐‐
You're a Harvard grad.
You don't have a gut.
You have
a business model.
Our gross margins online are,
what ‐‐ 75% or 80%.
So how isn't that translating
into 20%, pre‐tax?
That's what I
don't understand.
Okay.
So I will take that back ‐‐
I don't ‐‐
You know where you lost me,
if you want to be honest?
I loved your story,
but when you told me
you thought you were
gonna make 5%,
I knew you knew nothing
about your numbers. Nothing.
Well, at this point,
what do entrepreneurs focus on?
They focus on gross margin,
and they focus on top line.
I'm not focused on cutting
my costs or overhead costs,
because if I was ‐‐
You must have a plan.
36 months from now,
aren't you gonna try and make
$5 million in sales?
You're not focused on cutting
you costs or overhead costs?
At the moment, we're not.
I'm focused on gross margins,
as you guys
probably should be also at,
what ‐‐ year one?
You got ‐‐
When you come in,
you're not in Afghanistan.
You're in
the Shark Tank now.
You have to know
your numbers.
They do know
their numbers.
No, they don't.
They don't know
what their business model is.
Let me tell you, Mr. Wonderful,
once we hit profitability,
we're ‐‐
I'm sorry, guys.
I'm sorry.
You had me at the beginning,
but the minute I sensed
you didn't know your numbers,
I'm out,
and I am out.
Okay, guys,
I think your mission is good.
I think it's gonna be impactful
beyond just your product.
I've invested a lot
in military‐based companies.
You know, Combat Flip Flops
does a lot in Afghanistan.
So, um, I'm gonna offer you
the $250K for 15%,
and that's non‐negotiable.
Don't even think
about a counter,
'cause this is the number
or not.
Herjavec: Kim,
I'll make it really easy.
My offer was gonna be
$250,000 for 25%,
'cause I think ‐‐ I think you're
right on the starting point.
Mark's offer is better.
I'm not gonna compete on that.
I'm out.
What're you gonna do?
Mark, we'd like
to accept your offer.
That's what I'm
talkin' about!
[ Chuckles ]
Whoo!
Thank you, thank you,
thank you, thank you.
Congratulations, guys.
Thanks, Mark.
You guys are doing
great stuff.
Thanks, Mark.
All right,
guys, thanks so much.
Thanks, Mark.
Thank you, Sharks.
It was really nice
to meet you.
O'Leary: Thank you.
Take care.
Greiner: Congratulations.
Thank you.
Cuban: Thanks, guys.
Miller: Striking a deal with
Mark Cuban is a game‐changer
for the women in Afghanistan
who work for us,
for the farmers
in Afghanistan.
Now we're gonna have
the ability to scale
and bring our brand
to all the consumers in America.
I mean,
this is ‐‐ this is huge.
This is huge for us.
Cuban: It'll be good.
I'm expanding
my Afghani operations.
[ Laughter ]
Peoples:
We're gonna catch Mommy!
My name is Tyler Peoples.
I live with my wife, Cassie,
and my son, Josiah,
in Colorado Springs,
Colorado.
When I was born,
my mother suffered a stroke.
The doctors told her
that it was unlikely
that I was going to survive.
That left me deaf
until the age of 3.
But I've overcome
all of that now.
Growing up, my great‐grandma
taught me how to cook.
I got my first job as a grill
cook when I was a teenager.
I worked my way up
until I was the executive chef
at one of the best restaurants
in town, and I loved it.
But I just felt a calling
to feed people
who were truly hungry, so I left
the fancy restaurant life,
and I went to work at
the Springs Rescue Mission,
a homeless shelter
in our community.
Before they come in,
I want to make sure
we have nice hot coffee
ready to go.
After all those hours
in the kitchen,
I knew there was a product
I wished I had,
so I took the risk
and did it myself.
I've overcome a lot,
even at a young age,
and I think that's what's helped
me not be afraid to fail.
I know my product will become
a go‐to kitchen gadget.
And with the help of a Shark,
this could be huge.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Tyler Peoples.
My company is Peoples Design.
I come from Colorado Springs,
and I'm asking $75,000
for a 25%
stake in my company.
Peoples Design
is a company dedicated
to positive innovation.
Today, I'm here to show you
the Scooping Bowl.
The Scooping Bowl will become
your go‐to kitchen gadget.
Its unique and innovative design
will have you wondering,
"Why didn't I think of that?"
Sharks, this is what
we have right now.
A bowl for your salsa,
a bowl for your chips,
a bowl to mix your batter,
a rubber spatula,
a colander,
an egg separator.
Sharks, this is a mess.
You're doing dishes all night.
I know what you're thinking,
Sharks.
There's got to be a better way.
There is.
All right, Sharks,
this is the Scooping Bowl.
The Scooping Bowl will save you
time, space, and money.
Let me show you
how it works, guys.
We all love healthy
and delicious snacks.
Take your favorite fruits and
vegetables, pop them in here.
The blade holds the food back.
We're soaking, we're washing,
and we're straining, guys.
Same bowl washes,
strains, soaks.
[ Laughing ]
Wow.
Look at that.
That's amazing!
I like this boy.
Peoples:
You guys are loving this.
Hold on. There's more.
All right, guys,
look at this.
The silicone blade
cleans it, nice and dry.
Guess what, guys. I mentioned
an egg separator earlier.
Let me show you
how that works.
Instead of breaking out
two bowls,
getting your hands dirty,
guys, check this out.
The yolk stays back,
and the white slips through.
Let's see.
Can you guys see that?
Wow.
Let's make our favorite recipes,
right?
This is perfect for pancakes,
waffles, brownies,
cookies, birthday cake.
In one smooth motion,
the Scooping Bowl is gonna get
all of your expensive
ingredients right out.
Ahh.
Sharks, once you feel this
in your hands,
you're gonna get it,
and you're gonna love it.
I have one
for each of you.
Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
Wow.
Thank you very much, Tyler.
I'm gonna give one to Lori.
Thank you.
There you go, Lori.
O'Leary:
Thank you very much.
It's very cool.
I get blue.
John: Thank you.
Cuban: Thank you.
Tell us about you.
I'll tell you about me.
It's ‐‐
It's an unlikely story, guys.
When I was born,
the doctors told my mom,
"It's unlikely he's gonna
survive more than two weeks..."
Oh, wow.
Wow.
"...and if he does survive,
it's unlikely
he will ever gain his hearing,
and it's unlikely
that he will ever speak."
It's unlikely that a guy
with no culinary training,
the son of a housekeeper,
would become the head chef
at the best restaurant
in town.
It's unlikely that a guy
with no business training
would get a U. S. patent,
would find a manufacturer.
It's unlikely, guys,
but it's true.
And I want to invite you guys
to join this unlikely story.
All right,
tell us your story.
I worked at all sorts
of fancy restaurants,
and I cooked for thousands
of people, fine dining.
So I worked my way up.
I was the head chef
at a great restaurant in town.
And you know what?
I had in my heart
to do more,
so I left my job,
and I went to work
at the local rescue mission.
So, what happened?
How did you think of this?
I deal with bowls,
I deal with spatulas,
I deal with all this stuff
many, many times a day.
I struggle, it's annoying,
it's a mess, and I'm thinking,
"There's got to be a better
way," and I'm waiting
for somebody else
to make this dream real.
And I was tired of waiting.
Guys, I knew that if it was
gonna happen,
I was gonna make it happen.
Herjavec: So, Tyler...
Good for you, Tyler.
Tyler, where are you
in the product cycle?
Mm‐hmm.
Is this a prototype?
This is not a prototype.
I found a manufacturer,
and I have a utility patent.
What does it cost you to make,
and what do you sell it for?
It costs $5.80.
I sell it for $24.95.
And have you sold
any of them?
That's a great question.
Yes, I have sold.
How many?
[ Laughs ]
I've sold 200.
So, I know that's not
a great number.
Well, how have you done it?
Online?
I've done it trade shows
and gadget expos.
This, I believe, sells best
when people see it.
'Cause in a store, you wouldn't
know what this does.
Right.
Why would you leave
a great restaurant
to go work
at a mission?
Mm‐hmm.
Is there a personal ‐‐
He has a higher goal.
I always knew I wanted to feed
people who were hungry
and not just for food
but for opportunity.
And I don't know how many
thousands of people I've fed.
They weren't hungry.
They weren't.
Greiner: Are you able
to live on that, though?
What's helping you
to pay your rent?
I am.
At that shelter,
we serve over 150,000 meals
to the public,
so that's free of charge.
But it has a cost.
So, one way
to recoup the money
is we run a catering business,
and the catering business
employs men who have graduated
our addiction‐recovery program.
And I help
to fund the mission.
Good for you.
Wow.
Thank you.
Greiner:
Good for you.
Well, listen, Tyler, I'm gonna
take a flier on you.
I like you.
I think this is smart.
It's a better mouse trap.
Cooks will respond to it.
It's a great gadget
to have in the kitchen.
So I'm gonna make you
an offer ‐‐
$75,000 for 33 1/3% ‐‐
so that I will have
a third of the business
and you will have the rest,
and I will help you get this out
there into Bed Bath,
QVC, and all of that.
I think I can help you
get this everywhere.
But you need
to say yes now.
Narrator: All Sharks
are still in,
and Tyler has an offer
from Lori for his
multi‐use bowl company,
Peoples Design.
I think I can help you
get this everywhere.
But you need
to say yes now.
Cuban: Well, I'll simplify it
real quick, right?
My favorite utensil
in the kitchen is the phone
so I can call Campisi's to get
salad delivery, so I'm out.
Yeah, I'm out.
John: To me, there's too many
gadgets out there, honestly.
I‐I think people will buy it,
and they'll never use it,
even though it does work,
so I'm out.
All right, Kevin.
[ Chuckles ]
Um...
If ‐‐ If you don't take
that deal...
Yeah.
[ Laughing ]
O'Leary:
... right now...
Tyler,
it's a good deal.
I wouldn't wait.
Lori, would you consider
a royalty?
Ooh.
Greiner: A royalty?
What?!
A royalty.
Okay. Tell me what ‐‐
I'm curious.
What kind of royalty
are you thinking?
[ Sighs ]
How much per bowl?
$1 per bowl.
Mm.
I know it's
a valuable product.
I know people will buy it
when they see it.
And I know that a partnership
with you is priceless.
Here's what scares me.
'Cause, you know,
I've done over 500 products.
I know that when I first
started,
I'd go into JCPenney,
they gave me a chance,
and I would demonstrate
my earring organizer,
and I would sell
a hundred a day.
You've sold only 200
in all the trade shows
you've done so far.
Mm‐hmm.
So I'm taking a risk.
The reason why I want the third
is because I know the work
and the effort
that I'm gonna put in.
Okay.
I'm gonna get it
on QVC.
I have a built‐in audience
that trusts me and knows me.
But this is gonna take
a lot of work by my team
and myself to get this out there
into kitchen stores,
Bed Bath & Beyond,
all the places that it can be.
I'm just asking for 8% more
than what you offered,
but here's the thing.
You should answer me
right now.
I know my value.
Just as a reminder,
I make millionaires.
That's what I do.
My offer was $75,000
for 33 1/3%.
Yes or no, Tyler?
Um, Sharks,
I want to let you know
I'm gonna take this deal.
Yay!
[ Chuckles ]
Cuban: Smart.
Good.
I'm glad.
Not quite the fastest deal,
but...
Well, I know
it wasn't the fastest...
But good for you.
No, that's good for you, Tyler.
Well done.
Did a great job.
Thank you.
Well done, Tyler.
Thanks, Tyler.
Peoples: Striking a deal with
Lori means I can make an impact.
If you follow your dreams,
it is possible to achieve them.
My family's gonna
be very proud of me.
They've always believed in me,
and they ‐‐
they're gonna be proud.
♪♪